“It’s the 4th century BCE,
and Aristotle has just written
a critique of arguments
that take the truth of their conclusion
for granted.”
“It’s still the 4th century BCE,
and Aristotle has just advanced
a new theory:
that because Earth is the center
of the universe,
humanity is alone in the universe.”
He should listen to himself.
“It’s 1990,
and the Federal District Court of Virginia
is about to hear a prospective student’s
case against a university.
She has filed a complaint about
Virginia Military Institute’s
admissions policy that excludes women.”
“VMI is a publicly-funded university
that aims to produce ‘citizen soldiers’
through a unique and rigorous method:
all students are subjected
to an identical regimen
of extreme physical and mental stress
and deprivation of privacy.”
Well, I'm certainly not
sorry to be excluded.
“VMI is the only single-sex public
university in the state of Virginia;
there is no equivalent institution
for women.
Because VMI is a government institution,
by law, it cannot practice gender-based
exclusion
without ‘exceedingly persuasive
justification.’
It must prove that its single-sex
admissions policy
is a necessary step to serving
important governmental objectives.”
“The state of Virginia argues that VMI’s
educational methods
would be compromised by admitting women.
The state claims single-sex education
is an ‘important governmental objective’
and that the exclusion of women
from VMI is essential to that objective.”
Hmm, considering how much
they prize rigor,
their argument is certainly lacking it.
I’ll have to set them straight.
Come now, Your Honor.
Surely you can’t let that argument stand.
The state of Virginia is essentially
saying that single-sex education
should be allowed because it serves
the imperative of single-sex education.
You might as well say that witch hunts
should be encouraged
because they fulfill the need
for witch hunts.
These are examples of circular reasoning,
sometimes called “begging the question,”
where the reason given for a conclusion
assumes the conclusion is true,
rather than explaining why it’s true.
Take the conclusion that witch hunts
should be encouraged.
The evidence given is that there
is a need for witch hunts.
But both the claim and the so-called
evidence for the claim
leave the same question unanswered:
why are witch hunts necessary?
There actually isn't an argument
made here at all.
Circular reasoning may sound
straightforward, and in a way it is.
Even a human can easily spot the circular
logic in an argument like
“the baby was born because
her mother gave birth to her.”
Where you run into trouble
is when you assume
that an opinion or current state
of affairs,
because it’s so familiar or long-lasting,
is a fact, when really it’s an assumption.
Like the generations of astronomers
and mathematicians
who contorted themselves to explain
anomalies in the planets’ orbits,
rather than questioning the premise
that the planets orbited the Earth.
You modern humans may understand
that the planets actually orbit the sun,
but you're still susceptible
to assumptions of your own.
So you may hear “men and women
should be treated differently
because the law treats them differently”
and think, well, yes, that makes sense.
The law has always treated
them differently.
But that’s merely a statement of fact;
it’s not a reasoned argument
for why it should to be the case.
And just because something is true
doesn’t make it proof of what is right.
Not convinced? Well, I’m sure you,
as a judge,
won’t mind hearing a bit more evidence.
“It’s 1996, and the case has gone
all the way to the Supreme Court
of the United States.
The court has ruled 7 to 1
that VMI must begin to admit women.
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
delivers the ruling,
calling out the state of Virginia
for its circular reasoning.”
If I may, I'd like to bring my companion
here up to speed on your logic.
And while I’m at it, I’ll borrow that.
Now, let’s see.
She points out that Virginia’s
justification for excluding women from VMI
gave the means as an end—
that is, it argued that women
should be excluded
because the school’s mission
was single-sex education,
when in fact the school’s stated mission
was to produce citizen soldiers
prepared to take on leadership roles
in American society—
an aim, Justice Ginsburg asserts, that is
surely broad enough to include women.
Alone in my universe at last.